- All right, welcome everybody.
My name is Sohaib Katariwala.
I'm a senior OpenSearch specialist SA
with Amazon OpenSearch Service.
And joining me today is-
- Hey, I'm Joshua Bright,
product manager within the
OpenSearch Service team.
- And today, we're gonna be talking about
intelligent observability
and modernization
with Amazon OpenSearch Service.
So the takeaways for today's
session are gonna be,
first, we're gonna start a
little bit about, you know,
just using Amazon OpenSearch
Service for observability.
Then we're gonna go into
the new analytic features
that have been launched
over the past year.
And then finally, we're gonna talk about
agentic AI for observability.
So you want to make sure you
stick around for that one.
But before we dive into
the technical details,
let's first talk about Any Company,
a fictional company.
Any Company is a fast
growing e-commerce platform
that helps small and medium businesses
create their own marketplaces.
And the goal is it they're starting
to become more and more popular
with businesses looking to
compete with major retailers.
They have an architecture
that contains of modern microservices.
So their front end is React based
with a customer portal
and a vendor dashboard.
Their backend services are
order and payment management,
and inventory management
authentication, et cetera,
as you might have.
And then their infrastructure
is containerized services
on AWS using EKS.
And they are also using databases
like RDS and DynamoDB for
their databases, okay?
But they have some challenges
with this architecture.
Number one, we're gonna call
microservices complexity.
This is where Any Company's
distributed architecture
creates some visibility challenges
across lots of microservices
that they have.
When checkout failures
spike during flash sales,
teams are struggling to find
whether it's a payment
service that has the issue
or the inventory service that has an issue
or some sort of connectivity, right?
So that's the microservices complexity
that the first challenge is.
The second one we're gonna
call data pipeline chaos.
So with multiple data
sources and databases
and data formats from
different services coming in,
the administrators and engineers
face constant challenges,
making sure the pipelines are calibrated
and they're performing up to par.
The third is developer productivity.
So DevOps teams spend hours manually
looking through logs
and correlating issues
across traces and metrics,
and they need to write complex queries
to understand what's going on,
to build some custom visualizations
for the different stakeholders
that want to know what's going on
across our different applications.
And so it takes a lot of time
for these developers to be productive.
And then finally, cost management, right?
This is where the
observability data volume
continues to grow and explode
as with many customers.
For the past year, it's grown
over 300% for Any Company.
And they're continuing to scale,
which makes traditional monitoring
solutions cost prohibitive.
Are any of you facing
any similar challenges
in your organization?
I see some hands and some head shaking.
So this is what we hear from
a lot of our customers, right?
So we've kind of compiled these things
from all the customer
conversations that we have,
and we're representing it
through this fictional
company called Any Company.
Now what we see is the common challenges
that customers tell us every day,
most modern applications,
like the e-commerce platform
that Any Company has,
are distributed across
many, many services and microservices,
as you can see in the diagram.
And with these many
services and microservices,
the visibility into them
can be extremely low,
especially for inter
microservice interactions
and interaction with other AWS services.
When any companies
check out failures spike
during their Black Friday traffic surge,
their engineering team was left wondering
what was the issue?
Was it a bug in the checkout service?
Was it a payment,API failure?
Was it a database connectivity issue?
What's really going on?
And the reality is that these
decoupled code and services
are really, really hard to diagnose.
So each of Any Company's
components emit some signals
through logs, metrics and
traces also called telemetry,
and their checkout service logs errors,
payment service tracks,
transaction metrics, et cetera, et cetera.
And this is creating, you know,
a lot of different signals
and having to manually correlate
and find the needle in the haystack
becomes very challenging.
And this is where teams
get stuck during a crisis.
Recently, for example,
Any Company's main website went down
and engineers had to
manually grip their logs
and spent hours trying to find
what was happening across
their distributed system.
And so to remediate these
failures effectively,
you need analysis of interactions
and code across all these
distributed components.
This is where a unified
observability becomes critical,
and where a comprehensive
observability solution transforms
how Any Company's teams
can monitor, troubleshoot,
and optimize their modern
cloud native applications.
So what is an observability platform
and why is it useful?
Just to recap, an observability platform
collects information
from your entire system
in real time to help find
and resolve the unexpected
or unknown issues.
It helps the builders and administrators
efficiently detect, investigate,
and remediate issues.
So usually this is done by
creating insights over telemetry,
such as metrics, logs, and traces.
And an observability platform
offers developers the ability
to understand the applications better
and tools to analyze root causes
in the event of failures.
And as you know, it's
a very, very important
part of a workload.
Just like other things such as scalability
and loose coupling,
observability is very
critical to get right.
So AWS, as a whole, provides
many choices in monitoring
and observability services
that you can use to collect,
to store, to investigate an alarm on data
from your infrastructure
and your applications.
And together these services
compliment each other
by providing insights and analytics
using predefined instrumentation
and visualizations.
For example, Amazon CloudWatch,
which you can see there is a service
that monitors applications
and responds to performance changes.
It optimizes resource use.
It's really useful for simpler
real time performance monitoring
of your AWS environment.
And then you also see Amazon
managed service for Prometheus,
which is a managed monitoring
and alerting service,
which provides data
and actionable insights
for container environments
that are deployed at scale.
And then you also see
Amazon OpenSearch Service,
which allows for deep log analysis
for complex search needs across
logs, metrics and traces,
especially for longer
term data storage needs.
So as you've heard,
Any Company has a very complex tech stack
with many components
that require deeper analysis capabilities,
and they require longer term storage.
And this is what makes
Amazon OpenSearch Service
a great fit for Any Company.
So today, of course, we're going to focus
on achieving a world-class
level of data-driven insights
using Amazon OpenSearch Service,
and all the exciting new enhancements
and features that have been launched
that make achieving this
full stack observability
easier than ever.
So OpenSearch itself is a community-driven
open source platform, which
is extremely versatile
and covers lots of use cases
that include lexical search,
vector search, semantic search,
and then they also include observability.
And thousands of
customers trust OpenSearch
with their production workloads.
In 2024 and 2025,
OpenSearch Software Foundation
has become a project of
the Linux Foundation now.
So this is to foster an open collaboration
for search analytics and observability.
And as you can see, many
companies have already
joined the project that
you can see listed there
to continue supporting
the open source project
and the ecosystem.
The OpenSearch project continues to grow
with 1.3 billion downloads
and more than 3,400 active contributors,
and now at 28 releases.
And you can see many,
many members are joining,
contributors are joining.
So you know, one thing you
can take away from here
is if you're interested
in contributing back,
this is a great community to get with.
Now, Amazon OpenSearch Service
is an AWS managed service
that lets you run and
scale OpenSearch clusters
without having to worry about
the managing, the monitoring
and the maintenance of the infrastructure,
or having to have the expertise
in the operations of managing a cluster.
So that's what Amazon
OpenSearch Service gives you.
OpenSearch and OpenSearch
Service is a robust ecosystem
of tools that can make it easy and fast
to build a robust observability platform.
So to ingest, to filter, to transform,
to enrich the data and route
it from your applications
to OpenSearch domain or
serverless collection,
you can use the Amazon
OpenSearch Ingestion,
which is a feature of OpenSearch Service,
which is great at ingestion.
To store the data, you can
use either open source cluster
of OpenSearch that
you've deployed yourself
and managed yourself,
or what we recommend is to
use Amazon OpenSearch Service,
which takes all the administration
out of having to deploy it yourself.
And then to take it even further,
you can use Amazon OpenSearch Serverless,
which is completely zero administration,
automatic scaling, and
you pay for what you use.
And then finally,
to do application debugging,
to do visualizations,
and to analyze application behavior,
you can use OpenSearch Dashboards,
which is a purpose-built user experience
to get insights out of your data.
So now I'm gonna go into
each of these pieces
of the architecture and talk about
how Any Company can use OpenSearch Service
to accomplish their goal
of addressing those challenges
that we talked about earlier.
So first, we'll talk about
how Any Company can
start collecting signals
from their microservices
and pieces of their infrastructure, right?
So your applications,
just like any companies
can be either AWS native
or they could be custom applications
with infrastructure such as databases,
containers, virtual environments.
So Any Company collects these by running,
which generally called agents.
And agents are basically
small software processes
that run next to their application
or run in parallel to the
containers to collect metrics,
to collect logs and traces,
and export them forward to
the observability solution.
And one of the most popular mechanisms
for collecting the data
we see that AWS customers
using is OpenTelemetry.
It's a set of vendor agnostic SDKs
and libraries to instrument
your applications.
It supports logs, metrics,
and traces collection.
And due to the popularity,
we've seen many, many
vendors start to support it.
And so AWS also offers open
distribution of OpenTelemetry,
which is a way that supports natively
many, many AWS services.
And it offers collection
and storing telemetry into
the native AWS solutions
like OpenSearch Service.
So now Any Company sends their
data from these collectors
into Amazon OpenSearch Ingestion,
which is a feature of OpenSearch Service,
which gathers the data and buffers it
using its built-in buffering capability.
And then before writing it to OpenSearch,
you can transform the data.
So Any Company can transform it
to format the data in the
way that they would like,
and then they forward it to
Amazon OpenSearch Service.
They also enrich their data.
They can parse logs and metrics
during this ingestion
using OpenSearch Ingestion.
So now that the data is
collected, it's transformed.
Now, OpenSearch Ingestion
pipelines write this data
to Amazon OpenSearch
Service clusters or domains
for short to medium term
storage and analysis.
And then OpenSearch Service
also has built in tiering
that allows Any Company to retain data
for longer periods of time at lower costs.
So you may decide to
store some of the data
in OpenSearch into the hot
tier, and then a warmer tier
or directly in S3
as a really, really sort of
a cold level tier of data
and read it into OpenSearch
Service on demand.
All of this data has the insights
that Any Company needs to debug
or understand their applications.
Okay, so now the data is stored,
how do they surface this data
and allow their engineers and DevOps teams
to get insights out of it?
So to surface these insights,
OpenSearch Service comes
with a built in guided user experience
called OpenSearch Dashboards.
And now it's called OpenSearch UI,
which we will discuss in
detail in the next section.
So now that we've seen how
we've collected the data,
we've transformed it, we've stored it,
we can use dashboards.
Now we need to see how to measure
and gain insights from this data.
So let's go back to Any Company's
engineering team, right?
They need to know exactly what to measure
across their distributed architecture
and how to interpret those measurements
and turn them into
performance improvements.
So the DevOps teams need to
measure, check out latency,
they need to measure the response times
from the different services, et cetera.
So how will they be able to do that?
Well, they can use OpenSearch Dashboards,
which is a purpose built user experience
to get the most out of
your observability data.
So this is sort of the landing place
where you connect to OpenSearch
UI, OpenSearch Dashboards.
You see, you know the
dashboards that you've created.
It comes pre-configured with widgets
that give you insights that you need
and can help you perform
root cause analysis.
And it also offers the ability
to create new visualizations
with easy drag and drop capability.
Once you're happy with
your visualizations,
you can embed them in your applications
and it's multi-tenant,
which means you can have multiple teams
with access to different applications data
and have the right people
looking into the right data
that they're responsible for.
Now the analysts and developers
can also use something called
the Discover experience.
Discover is used to explore the data
using a variety of different
supported languages,
including Dashboard Query
Language, Lucene, standard SQL,
and PPL, pipe processing language,
as well as natural
language queries as well,
which you can see in the screenshot below,
powered by Amazon Q.
So when you're debugging
or when you're analyzing
application behavior,
you need an ability to filter,
to calculate statistics,
to sort the data, right?
That gives you the insights
that you're looking for.
OpenSearch Service has a powerful
pipe processing language,
which you can use to filter
and measure various metrics or KPIs.
For example, you can
construct your desired outcome
in a step-by-step manner
with each step getting you closer
to your desired result.
Now Dashboards and the
Discovery experience
are really good if you are there
and you're looking at them
and you know what to go after.
But what if you're not around, right?
What if you're not act actively logged in
and looking at this user experience
and you really want the
observability solution
to keep an eye on the
application telemetry for you?
So open source service
has a robust monitoring
and anomaly detection capability,
which keeps an eye on your data
and sends you an alert
in the case of a failure,
or in the case that it finds any unusual
or anomalous patterns.
And you don't really need any
machine learning experience
to configure these anomaly
detectors and set up alerts,
which makes it really popular
amongst Any Company's teams.
So speaking of alerts, notifications,
you can receive these notifications
in a variety of different
ways or channels,
and you can send it to your
favorite Slack channel.
For example, Any Company's
teams routed their Slack channel
and they route it to their mobile devices
using their built-in alerting
and incident management tools
such as PagerDuty or Opsgenie.
And generally you have a
link back to the dashboards
in the notification that
is sent to these channels.
So the developers can
quickly click on that link
and continue the investigation
by logging into the UI.
So the other experience,
what we see is, you know,
microservices are very common
amongst most of our customers
that we talked to today.
And when you're working
with microservices,
there are many moving parts
and investigating all
of these moving parts
can be difficult.
So to make this simpler,
we use what's called traces, right?
Traces will capture the communication
between different services
so that you can know what happens
when a service calls another service,
was it successful or not, et cetera.
OpenSearch Dashboards offers
purpose-built visualizations
that analyze this data.
We have something called a service map
with which you can see
if there's any error
in your application at a glance
or if your applications
are facing any issues
with higher latency and
error rates, et cetera.
You also have something called
Trace Group Visualization,
which groups related traces together
into a single widget and allows you
to see if a certain function
in your application,
for example, a checkout
is facing an issue, right?
So now with these different
visualization capabilities,
you can pinpoint exactly where to look,
you can uncover the logs
that cause the issues using traces,
and then you can start
analyzing those logs.
So now the volume of operational data
that customers need to
analyze is continuing to grow.
As we hear from many customers,
the data volumes are continuing to grow.
The same thing with Any Company.
OpenSearch Service already
supports observability workloads
up to 25 petabytes.
And of course, in the
future, like everything else,
it's continuing to grow.
To meet this growing scale,
customers often store operational data
across multiple OpenSearch
Service deployments.
Maybe they have multiple clusters,
maybe they have some clusters
and some OpenSearch
serverless collections, right?
And customers are
increasingly asking OpenSearch
to work across multiple data sources.
So they want the dashboard experience,
but they don't want to tie
it to a specific cluster.
So to centralize all this data management
and give this view in a single place,
we've launched a next
generation OpenSearch UI.
The next generation OpenSearch UI
is an independent dashboard application,
which is designed to
help customers aggregate
comprehensive insights
into a single unified view,
which allows you to see and view data
across multiple OpenSearch
domains and collections.
And currently, applications
can be associated
with multiple OpenSearch clusters,
OpenSearch serverless collections,
and even other sources
like direct query to S3.
Now that all these dashboard
instances are consolidated,
it becomes even more important
to have a way to organize the data
and the dashboards from
the different sources,
the different alerts, the
different saved queries.
So that's why we introduced
workspaces in OpenSearch UI.
With workspaces, you can
easily create your dashboards,
save them, and as well as
your alerts and queries
in a private space.
This private space allows
you to manage permissions
tailored to how your team
needs to share their data.
And workspaces gives
you a curated experience
for popular use cases as
well, such as observability,
such as security analytics, et cetera.
So you can find it
straightforward to build content
for your use case.
Workspace also supports
collaborator management
so that you can share your workspace
only to your intended
collaborators, right?
And manage permissions for each
collaborator as you'd like.
So while that was all launched last year,
there have been some exciting updates
and features that we've
added to OpenSearch UI
this year so far.
And now I'll turn it over to Joshua
to walk you through those new updates now.
- Awesome, hey, thanks Sohaib.
I really appreciate it.
Everybody able to hear me okay?
Okay, perfect.
Before I get started in talking about,
you know, what's new
within OpenSearch Service,
I wanted to just take a moment.
We're on the heels of
Thanksgiving holiday,
so I just want to thank
all of OpenSearch customers
as well as the community,
open source community.
We really appreciate your partnership
and really love working
backwards with you.
And I look forward to announcing
more what's new features next year
in conjunction with you.
Okay, so the What's new
section is gonna be two parts.
So one of them is more of your visual
deterministic analytics
with OpenSearch UI.
That'll be my section.
And the second section
will be with Sohaib,
who will be talking about
agentic development.
Let's go ahead and get started though.
So we looked into the
issues that Any Company
was, you know, calling out as as problems.
And we realized that, you know,
it seemed like everyone
was trying to solve this
with more features and more complexity.
We took kind of the opposite approach.
What if we made log analytics simpler,
not more complex?
You know, what if we
prioritize the user experience
instead of adding additional features
and bolting things on?
And that's what we've done.
With OpenSearch UI's
observability workspace,
we've made pipe processing language,
the language that Sohaib
were talking about
a little bit earlier,
we made that as the forefront
and we've segmented it
or complimented it with AI
in the form of natural language
as well as with a result
summarization feature.
So now we've made this
experience integrated,
instead of it being kind
of this bolted on workflow,
now you can query with PPL
and supplement it with the
natural language experience.
Pretty great.
So in addition to that though,
we've also made it easier to ingest
data from OpenTelemetry
so that teams like those at Any Company
can go from their raw data
to actionable insights
with very little effort.
And let me give you a concrete
example of what I mean.
So Any Company's data admins
were complaining, right?
Like, hey, it takes a lot of time for me
to set up these pipelines
that I want to ingest it into OpenSearch
or into other log analytics tools.
Gotta configure parsers.
You probably have all run into this,
configure all of your mappings,
and you're kind of debugging
and playing Whack-a-Mole
trying to figure out like why data
is not landing the way
that you would expect.
This setup is a lot of
overhead and super frustrating
when you're just trying to
get something out the door.
So our approach kind of
flips this completely.
We provide out of the box blueprints
that will get things set up for you.
So we cover things, you
know, popular AWS logs,
certainly like ALB logs,
CloudTrail logs, Lambda logs,
as well as third party
logs like Jira integration,
OpenTelemetry, certainly as
well as HTTP Apache logs.
So, but that wasn't enough.
We also wanted to make the
workflow fundamentally easier.
So we have a new get started workflow,
you can see it in the OpenSearch console
where you have this new setup
that allows you to set up
an OpenTelemetry pipeline.
All the bells and whistles are included,
you point it over at your cluster
and it will automatically set up
an OpenSearch UI instance for you.
So no more dilly dallying
trying to get your proof of concepts up
or new pipelines super easy.
So Any Company's teams can now get started
analyzing their logs,
whether that be their react front end,
whether order processing service
or recommendation engine
in minutes instead of days.
But even when you get through
the onboarding, right?
You hit another wall,
which is actually being
able to utilize the tooling.
So customers like Any Company told us
that they have lots of queries
and dashboards that already
set up in another tool.
You know, they don't want
to relearn a new tool,
a new language, or new workflows.
So we made a fundamental decision.
We made pipe processing
language feel familiar.
If you know pipe delimited
languages from, you know,
Unix or other tools,
you'll feel at home in OpenSearch Service.
We aligned our syntax, our commands,
our functions to feel natural.
And the result, Any Company's teams
existing knowledge becomes an asset.
It's not a liability.
And their migration from
which was gonna be taking,
you know, six months, you know, to a year
now is something that can be accomplished
within, you know, a few weeks.
But language is just the start, isn't it?
You need also need the right words,
or in this case, commands
to express the complex ideas
that you're interested in extracting.
So over the past year,
we've more than doubled
pipe processing language capabilities.
We've added joins and lookups
to be able to join indices together.
We've added comprehensive
time analysis commands
like time chart and event stats
that allow you to
understand events over time.
And in addition, we've
included the ability
to extract unstructured data,
not possible in in OpenSearch currently.
The ability to extract the data
and create new fields
for your analysis using rex and spath.
So this isn't about just
like adding more features,
it's about having the right tools
to ask sophisticated
questions of your data.
And now Any Company can
correlate their checkout failures
with their recommendation engine
in a single query.
Let me show you what I mean.
Anyone can write a query that says,
show me all the errors, right?
That's table stakes.
But observability isn't
just about collecting data,
it's about asking sophisticated questions.
And the real insights
come from when you can
quickly identify errors
that are occurring, quantify
how large the impact is,
and understand the next course of action.
For Any Company, that means
connecting checkout failures,
with their authentication
service performance,
and payment processing latency.
That's where you find the
root cause, not just symptoms.
And now you have all
the tools that you need
to gather those insights.
Any Company's teams were
losing quite a few hours
moving in between workflows as well.
So we talked a little bit
about a familiar syntax,
we talked a little bit
about the new commands
and functions that exist.
The last piece that we wanted to target
was the improved user experience
and streamlining that.
So at Any Company, they were moving
between the querying experience
and the visualization building experience
and the dashboarding experience.
And what we've done is we
said, okay, forget all that.
Like let's consolidate everything
into the discovery experience.
And so what we've done
instead is we've built out
that those different
workflows into discover.
So now when you analyze your data,
you're also able to not only do that
from a results perspective,
but also you can enhance
and compliment that with visualizations.
And then very easily be able to add
that into your dashboard.
So no longer are you kind of moving in
between different areas
of your logging tool.
You can capture all of
those critical things
that you need to set up
and support your APIs all within Discover.
So now you know, folks can stay
in the flow from question
to answer to action.
And this applies to
your data in OpenSearch,
but certainly applies to
the data where it rests.
So as Sohaib mentioned,
we also have integrations
with Amazon S3 for
historical and audit logs.
Your data in CloudWatch logs.
Instead of piping your data
from CloudWatch logs into OpenSearch,
you can analyze your data in
CloudWatch logs from OpenSearch
and then certainly from, you know,
doing security investigations
for Security Lake.
So let's bring this together.
We've built our solution on
three pillars, easy startup.
So you have easy startup
with these new blueprints
that allow you to get started
with very common log types,
been able to create this
new get started workflow
that allows you to very quickly
create the new pipelines
and utilize OpenSearch UI.
I, we've made it easier to get started
because we built out a familiar syntax
that everyone coming from pipe
languages easily understands.
And we've also made it easy to get started
by incorporating the
natural language prompts
within the querying experience itself.
So you can ask questions of your data
and get that analysis back.
And if that wasn't enough,
we also have the AI summarization feature,
which allows you to understand
as you type in your query,
it will summarize the results
and provide you an understanding
of what is in the result set.
So that's kind of the
easy startup section.
The next section that we did
is we added additional
commands and functions
in pipe processing language
to really unlock insights
like never before.
And then last, we created
a cohesive work experience.
So now you no longer have to move in
through different workflows.
You can accomplish all of your insights
right within OpenSearch Discover
and be able to very easily
create your visualizations
and add those over into a dashboard.
I'm gonna go on ahead
and get over to the demo
'cause there's a lot of talking,
but I like to see action.
So we'll move over to the demo next.
What we're gonna do is we're going to-
we understand that there's a problem
with the load generator service.
And so what we're gonna do
is we're going to query
the load generator service
or understand what kind of
errors are coming through.
So here, I do a simple where statement
which pulls all of the
errors from the logs.
And that's cool.
So now we can see that
the load generator service
is showing up.
For the next section,
what we'll do is I wanna
show off this unstructured,
the ability to pull out unstructured data.
So I'm gonna show here that
we have the rex command,
which allows you to extract the data
using regular expression.
So you can see in the table below
that you have error type
as well as error message.
Really, and the nice thing
is we have all of these
different types of visualizations
that you can select from
right within the discovery experience.
So that's what I mean about
having this comprehensive
and cohesive experience.
It's all within discover,
no more kind of having to move around
to accomplish those tasks
that you were hoping to do before.
Next, what I would like to do
is understand the error rate.
So you know, I'm going to
be filing a ticket 'cause-
So I'm gonna do this investigation,
I need to file a ticket.
So I need to understand what's happening
from an error perspective.
So you can see I use event stats,
which allows me to track
the error over time.
And I'm doing the total_events
as well as the error_count above
and calculating the error rate.
I don't know about you,
but 16% error rate,
that's no bueno, that's no bueno.
So we gotta do better and
I'm gonna assign this ticket
to someone who's going to help us out.
In order to do that though,
'cause I don't inherently know
where the ticket needs to go,
I'm going to join our this erroe data
with our service catalog.
So now with-
But before we do that,
we need to understand
when the error had occurred
so that we can fill out
the ticket properly.
So we use the time chart command
to go on ahead and
understand what happened.
And so with this lovely visualization,
I'm able to very quickly understand
when the error started,
when the error ended,
so I can fill out the full
case detail of this ticket.
And then last, that's
when we get to the join.
So I have a service catalog off the side,
it has all of the details of
who is responsible for what.
And now I'm able to join
my data across the errors
or the logs with the service catalog data.
And I see that Charlie,
oh, unfortunately Charlie is in trouble.
Charlie is going to get a ticket.
But now you know,
I think that's a really great thing.
So now we have all sorts
of these new commands,
pipe processing language
that we weren't able
to do before with DQL.
So now we're able to unlock
all sorts of new insights
and we're really excited about that.
But what if you're not, you know,
a piped language expert or guru?
Well, I talked a little bit earlier about
the AI assistant that helps
you build out your queries.
So I can very easily just come in here
and type out an English prompt.
The nice thing is not
only do I get the results,
fantastic of course,
but I also get the PPL statement as well.
So you're able to learn with-
you're able to learn as
well as get the results
that you need using
this language assistant.
And I can iterate on it.
See, so now I can go
over into the query bar,
make adjustments to the
query if I wanted to.
So super easy.
But let's say it's 2:00 in the morning
and I got paged super frustrating.
I know what we've all been there.
I have the AI summary feature as well.
So I can go and execute the query
and then use the AI summary feature
to extract those insights
from the results set
to very quickly give me hints
as to what to do next and who to contact.
I mentioned the visualizations
and all of the options that
we have with visualizations,
but really it is as easy
as you execute your query,
you analyze your results,
you get that perfect visualization
that you need for, you know,
supplemental materials for your ticket
and you can add it to a dashboard
from right within the discover experience,
Bada bing, bada boom.
Now we got a dashboard.
Easy, easy.
So what's even easier, right?
We talked about, you
know, having a easy setup,
great rich analytics experience,
cohesive experience from
a discover visualization.
Sohaib is gonna talk to us
about agentic development.
So looking forward to that.
- Thank you.
All right, now the exciting stuff, right?
So we've seen how Any Company
engineers and analysts
can use this improved UI experience
to easily get started to
use familiar languages
and analyze data using
a rich set of features
and query languages to reduce
the time to resolution.
But you know, before I
jump into the next thing,
which is a separate team in Any Company
wants to take it really
even a step further,
they want to know how they can use AI
and agents to help with
the same kind of things
that we saw to speed up investigations
and the time to resolution
without needing to even have
any engineers and analysts
using this UI experience.
And so what we hear from customers
are these two different
sort of requirements, right?
One is how can we work
without having a team
of engineers and analysts?
So this is where teams
are, you know, staff short
and they don't have the time to go
and do the investigation
and use PPL like we saw.
And this is where they could
use the help of an AI agent.
And there are other teams where
they already have engineers
and analysts that are
used to using these tools
and they just wanna make it easier
and they prefer to go themselves
and build visualizations
and build these integrated
queries and visualizations.
So they want the best of both.
They want the ability to easily do the UI
and they also want this
easy agentic experience.
And that's why we have
the second piece of it,
which is how can we use AI agents
to make this even easier.
So Any Company wants to provide
deep and actionable visibility
to AI agents that can monitor
and analyze and reason
and improve observability process
within their organization.
They want to have an AI agent
that has access to tools
such as the list of indexes
in the OpenSearch clusters
and other data sources
that Joshua showed like S3
and CloudWatch, et cetera.
And they want this AI agent
to be able to get the metadata
from the OpenSearch cluster as well
to see what are all the indexes there,
what are they called,
what are the fields there
so that it can properly
know which fields to query
and where to run the filters.
And they want to do this very easily
to get started and do a quick POC to see
does this work before they
decide to move, you know,
if they wanna move this into production.
So they wanna see how
can we start to do this
and what steps can we start using
to try to remediate future issues
as well using AI agents.
And so this is where one
of the main components
of OpenSearch becomes helpful,
where, you know, OpenSearch
already has a capability
called model context protocol or MCP.
I'm sure you've heard a lot about it
in many other sessions,
but just as a recap.
Traditionally connecting
multiple AI agents
to different data sources
required individual connections
from each of the agents to each source.
And so MCP simplifies this
by introducing a centralized component.
This component handles
all the boilerplate code for connectivity
for making the system more
efficient and manageable.
The MCP consists of
these two parts usually
where you have a MCP
server and an MCP client.
The server is a lightweight program
that invokes the rest APIs
of services like OpenSearch
Service in this case
and the server and the
client is an adapter
for allowing the AI agent
to use the servers functionalities.
And for OpenSearch specifically,
it has this MCP server in
the open source community.
It was developed by the community
and it's community-driven
development and support.
So that's one major
benefit of using OpenSearch
in the OpenSearch MCP server.
It has flexible communications
and its support standard I/O protocols
as well as streaming and it's adaptable.
And then it has a comprehensive
suite of tools available.
Read-only tools such as, you know,
the ability to search data,
the ability to check
the clusters held itself
and check the performance
metrics, et cetera.
And then finally, has
robust security options
with different authentication methods.
So we've put together a
quick demo for Any Company
to show the power of using this MCP server
to connect to OpenSearch
with their AI agents.
For this demo, I'm using
Amazon Q Developer CLI,
which is now renamed
to Kiro, you know, CLI
as you might hear about it as well.
So to easily get started,
this is a very simple architecture
where we have Q Developer CLI,
we have the MCP server stood up
and connected to the Q Developer CLI,
and it knows about the OpenSearch cluster
through the MCP server.
So to set context for the demo
that I'm gonna be showing you.
It's a POC demo.
It's Black Friday morning
for Any Company, right?
Traffic is 10 times normal levels
and suddenly checkout
failures start occurring.
The engineer team gets alerts,
but they're overwhelmed with data
from many, many different microservices
also sending alerts.
And this is where they wanna see
if the AI observability agent
powered by the MCP server
can come to the rescue.
So here I already have
Q Developer CLI launched
and I've already connected it
to the OpenSearch MCP server,
which you can see at the top.
It's loaded already successfully.
And so right away we can
just start asking questions.
So the first thing what
we wanna do is, you know-
oh, by the way, this is the indexes
that exist in my
OpenSearch cluster already.
So there is anycompany-app-logs index,
there is an anycompany-metrics index
and then there's a traces index.
We've put them in the same cluster,
but they could be across
different sources.
So the first question we're
gonna ask is, you know,
we're seeing increased error rates
across our checkout services.
Can you investigate what's happening
and provide us a root cause analysis?
So the agent uses all
the tools that it has
to figure out what's going on.
So immediately we can see
that it starts running queries
against the OpenSearch cluster,
against the indexes to fetch the data.
And we can even see the query that it ran,
we can see the index name
is anycompany-app logs,
we can see the cluster name.
And then we can also see additional things
such as filter clauses
in the query itself.
It's filtering for a
service called checkout.
You know, this is so useful for analysts,
which they don't have to write queries.
And usually, when you write
a query you have to run it
a bunch of times and maybe adjust it
and we can see the agent does that also.
You know, the first query
didn't get the right results.
So it actually went back to another tool
called index mapping
to learn more about what's the metadata,
what fields exist,
and then rewrite the query
using the correct field names.
And then it does the same
thing again and again
through the other indexes
that seem relevant.
So it checks traces as well.
And it also checks metrics.
And it keeps going back and forth
between running queries, checking metadata
for what fields exists in my index,
and then readjusting the filters to apply,
let's check this field,
let's check this field, et cetera.
So it's going through and
running multiple queries.
So useful to save, you know,
hours and hours of time
of a human having to do all of this.
And then finally it takes
all the data gathered
from all the queries
and synthesizes it together
into a single analysis.
So it tells us, you know,
based on the investigation of the data,
here's what happens.
So first we get a timeline
of events, super useful.
We know at 10:00 AM things were normal,
and then at 10:30, there
was an incident peak
and it gives us the data points
to prove why it thinks
that's the incident peak
because it saw error rates spiking.
And then finally it gives
us an actual root cause,
which is what we were looking for.
And the primary cause
is because, you know,
the service was unavailable,
the checkout service became unavailable.
So now we know that this checkout service
is really what caused
all the subsequent alerts
and issues that started
the whole snowball.
And it even gives us
from the trace analysis.
One specific service name
called process order,
which had the error starting.
So now we want to dive
a little deeper, right?
We say okay, the checkout
errors seem to be related
to the payment processing.
Can you trace the request flow
and identify where the actual
bottleneck is occurring
that caused these issues to happen?
So again, it'll go through
basically the same process.
Again, it's running some queries.
You'll see the queries are
a little bit different now.
The filters are different.
It's looking for payment first
and then it'll synthesize this data
to try to find what's
the actual bottleneck
that caused that service
to fail and give errors.
Okay, so now it's going
to get the trace flow.
We can even see trace IDs.
So it's identify, okay, trace_003 and 004
correlate to this issue.
So we'll dig in deeper to
those specific trace IDs
and find the correlated logs.
Again, you know, saves hours of time
for a human to have to
do all this analysis.
And then finally, it's going
to look further into the logs.
And now metrics.
So any related metrics,
if not, it can just kind of ignore that.
So now it's synthesized all of that.
And now let's see what the bottleneck is.
The bottleneck identified in this case
seems to be the database
timeout and the payment service.
And so it gives us another
bit of data that's helpful,
but really at the bottom
you see the root cause.
That's where the helpful
piece of information
is that I was looking for,
which is tell me what the root cause is.
And primary issue seems to
be the connection timed out
after 5000 milliseconds
on our database service.
So due to the spike of
queries against our database,
the queries are running slower
and then eventually they hit a timeout,
which cause the errors,
which cause other downstream effects
and it even shows us other
failures that are correlated.
So super helpful.
And then, you know,
again, it summarizes it.
Also, if you wanted, you could
kind of copy and paste this
and send it to leadership
to say, okay, here's what's going on.
And now of course what
we wanna know is, okay,
we identified the issue,
what's the impact, right?
What's the impact of this timeout?
And how can we fix it?
That's the next natural questions.
So we'll ask the agent,
the next question is:
what's the business impact of
this issue actually occurring
and how many customers are affected
and what's the revenue
at risk from this issue?
Okay, so yeah, this is the
next question, business impact.
So the interesting thing
is we also have some
non logs related data that
we've given the agent access to.
So we've given this agent access
to our sales tables as well.
So we can see previous sales history.
And in this case, it's
able to not only associate,
you know, the logs and traces and metrics,
but to find the impact.
It actually queries our sales history
to find the normal order volume
and the average order amount
and the ordered dollar value
so that it can try to estimate
based on the number of
orders that we were seeing
and how many errors we had
and the average dollar value,
what's the potential lost
revenue there directly.
And that's really helpful
if you wanna quickly
send leadership update to say, okay,
this is how many orders we
might have lost because of this.
And the potential future
impact of customers churning
because they were not able to
full complete their checkouts.
They would've bought, but they didn't.
And so it kind of goes
through all that math
right here, right?
You could see average order value
is from the e-commerce data,
then there's normal traffic,
incident response as well.
I am trying to see if I
can speed this up for you
because I think you get the idea.
But it's a lot of good data in there
to see the checkout
service issues, et cetera.
Okay, so now what we're gonna do
is we're going to ask the agent
to, based on the analysis,
what's the recommended
remediation step, right?
How can I fix this issue now?
And then also, how can
I prevent this issue
from occurring in the future again?
So that's a different
question to kind of ask
after we establish the business impact,
which you can kind of see there.
So now what I'll do is I'll ask the agent,
tell me what I can do to fix it,
but not just tell me now,
why don't you create a document for me?
Create a document for me,
you know, save it locally,
that gives me all the steps I need to do.
And then I can share that
document with my engineers,
I can share it with my leadership
and it should give me all the steps
that I should take right away
and the steps that I need to
take in the next week or so,
the steps I need to
take in the next month.
And then, you know, in
the next few months.
So it created a comprehensive
remediation plan
and it even wrote it out to my local path.
You can see it's called
payment incident runbook.
And it goes through all the things I need
to do to fix this issue.
And then, yeah, I used
the right tool to do this
and then also created
a different document,
which is a runbook for future issues
that our on-call engineers might face.
So now it's doing that.
Okay, and just similar to the first one,
I think you get the idea
that it creates a runbook,
it saves it locally.
And I just wanna show
you what that looks like.
So here's the payment
processing remediation plan
that I've just opened up.
I don't know why this monitor
is jittering like that,
but it provides even the
database alter statements
that I need to do to change
the connectivity issue that we saw.
And those are the short term fixes
that need to happen right away.
And then it also provides
some long term fixes
that we should see.
So it's giving us the
actual database commands
for the engineers to do.
Okay, so I think we get the idea-
That's essentially a quick
demo of what can be done.
Of course to productionalize it,
you can use something like, you know,
AgentCore to build an agent in production
that has similar capabilities.
So what we saw today was we
saw automatic correlation.
The observability agent
was able to correlate
and connect data from different indexes
for logs, metric, traces and sales data
without any human input.
It was able to explain what
it found in natural language
that was easy to understand for humans
as well as data points that it used
to justify the conclusions.
And it also suggested
preventative measures
for future events like
Black Fridays as well.
And in near real time,
you know, you could see
it's updating its database
with the memory of this incident.
So that if something similar
happens in the future,
it can also use a memory to
help make that process faster
since it can remember
this happened in the past
and this is what we did to fix it.
So it wouldn't even have to potentially
go and do all this research
this next time around.
So before the AI agent,
this would've taken hours and hours
and would've cost thousands of dollars
in the meantime where we're
trying to figure it out.
But with the AI agent,
now you could see within
a few minutes, you know,
eight minute end to end when I ran that
was to come up with all the
answers to all our questions.
And for Any Company,
this could be, you know,
70, 80% in a reduction
in the incidents impact
with the the short amount
of time it takes, right?
So thank you all so much.
If you wanna go deeper into
this type of demonstration
and get more hands-on, get more deeper,
we have a chalk talk coming
up later on this week,
that's ANT-330.
You can see that there.
Make sure to check that out.
And you can ask questions
and do the architecture
for how to build something like this
that's even more in depth
and has more capabilities.
If you wanna learn more about
how to use MCP yourself,
we have a blog about it
and then we also have documentation
on all the observability
features that we talked about.
So make sure you check those out.
And then also, if you wanna learn more
and you wanna level up
your skills on OpenSearch
and other AWS services,
check out skillbuilder.aws.
There's thousands of free resources there
and you can start, you know,
scan to start learning.
Okay, thank you so much
for attending our session.
Remember to fill out the survey.
And if you have any questions,
we can be here for a
few minutes afterwards.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)